i mean this show is just so incredible i
believe you've just started production
on season five is that correct so what
new challenges are the duttons going to
face what are you able to share
well it's always that sort of
the problem is how do we top it every
year right but i mean some of the same
challenges
protecting the land looking after my
father protecting him
um and just when i think beth might be
trying to you know maybe mellow down a
bit she's a married woman
that's not happening um i mean the
married woman part's happening but
they're calming down so it's just uh the
fierceness is is is uh is legitimately
ramping up oh it's at a level 10 which
that's what we love that's what we love
that before right that's what i was
going to ask since beth just got married
i mean what does newlywed life look like
is it any different
well in a strange way you know i think
beth is quite old-fashioned you know in
her values somewhere i think um i think
the fact that this man is now her
husband it holds a lot of power i think
in her i think but he's always been her
a guy i mean since she was 16 years old
he's the only man other than her father
that she's ever loved so the fact that
now she is uh she is it's official in
god's eyes and uh it's something that i
think she's incredibly proud of and i
think it probably gives her a little bit
more
stability yeah um that box is checked
you can focus on other things yes
exactly yeah now how exciting is this
how do you feel about helen mirren and
harrison ford joining this universe
joining the dutton family for 1932 i
mean what what do you think of that well
i just found out about this yesterday
and i'm i want to be in it basically
which is impossible
um but they're my ancestors i mean it
started with tim and faith and isabel
and and now um and now helen mirren is
someone who i did my very very first tv
job called prime suspect when i was 16
years old she was the first professional
actor i worked with how fast of a moment
is this then well kind of it was a long
time ago but she was uh she was
incredible she was fierce and brilliant
and everything i wanted to be as an
actor
you know full of courage and heart and i
well thank you that's what she is but um
and the fact that she is such a big fan
of the yellowstone universe show and
their writing i mean who isn't of this
writing it's so juicy um and the fact
that she is now going to be playing one
of beth darton's ancestors if it's a
really sweet thing and i'm i'm so
excited to see it i'm so
well then lastly any advice for her i
mean not that hallamir needs advice but
what does she need to know going into
the yellowstone universe
she doesn't need advice she's got it i
mean she's so smart and i and it doesn't
surprise me that this is up her street
at all i mean these fiery women
fighting
for their for their land and doing it
with soul and grit and like that is i
mean you think about those characters
that she's she's got such sovereignty
and a regality but also that sort of you
know you know she's kind of you know she
can kick it to the dirt as well you know
so it's part of that i feel very excited
for taylor sheridan that he's going to
get to work with her it's two giants and
harrison ford i mean that's hello yeah i
mean these are these are acting heroes
of mine so we helped create this kind of
dislike yeah i'm part of it i'm part of
it so i would definitely be coming on a
set visit there and and and saying hello
so it's it's it's you know it's
testament to the fans i think because
you know you're only as good as how many
people are watching your show if we if
they didn't show up for season two to
watch this this season then we wouldn't
have got uh we wouldn't have been we
would be making season three in the fact
that it's just
you know been climbing and climbing and
now people can't ignore us you know
we're here
[Music]